one of the most productive things that
you could do is actually to learn a
skill set because when this is over when
this thing is over and it will be over
there's only a matter of time the well
will start spinning again what are you
gonna do right
maybe that you'll need to be concerned
that maybe you have unfortunately lost
your job but when things get back to
normal you'll go out there and get a new
job are you ready are you prepared
because things are different now things
have changed industries have changed the
world has changed so are you ready are
you are you prepared to go after that
new opportunity or maybe go after that
other job that you've always wanted or
maybe go for that new promotion or go
start that new business whatever you
want to do after this crisis what would
allow you to do a lot those things are
your skills I believe during this lock
down some of the most valuable skills
that you could develop that you could
learn meet these four criteria number
one a skill set that has an immediate
impact on your life your career or your
business not a skill set that it takes
years to see any results but something
that you can learn right now and you
could implement something that's very
very practical second that it doesn't
take you years to learn that you don't
need to go back to school again for four
years of education instead you can learn
these skill sets in months or sometimes
in a matter of weeks number three that
you can learn from the comfort of your
own home that you don't need to go to a
physical location you can learn this
from your computer just from your own
home number four you can learn at your
own pace meaning that if you want to
binge watch and binge learn you could do
that or you want to pace yourself you
want to learn it through a period of
time maybe over a number of days or
number of weeks in your spare time you
could do the
as well so I believe skillsets that meet
these four criteria those are very
valuable skill sets to learn you will
kick yourself in the ass
they're not taking advantages I had
people tell me not in the last year or
two but five years ago that were still
around from the big oil collapse that I
witnessed then we thought you were crazy
how did you how did you maintain your
resolve how did you keep your nerve just
keep running into the gunfire and
borrowing money now if oil had stayed at
five six dollars a barrel what I would
have been with a transcended bankruptcy
because there was virtually no way in
humanly possible that I could have ever
ever ever paid back all that money the
every soldier once said to not be alone
in the foxhole and that's why a lot of
guys turn to religion this isn't
changing my attitude about you know
familiarity breeds contempt poorness
rubs off and this is a tie for you not
to be a pleaser this is a time for you
to get ruthless this is a time for you
to get selfish to provide your family a
you and your family with the riches I
believe you deserve now if you don't and
I'm wrong and Corona last twice as long
as I think and you haven't taken
advantage of this opportunity you're
going to be big-time
you're gonna go down the toilet with
everybody else go out there run towards
the gunfire and kill him dead I'm
playing a game that most people really
don't understand I'm playing the network
game you know I'm doing an independent
game most people don't understand what
that means but you know what it means
that me you could still hustle in the
pandemic you know you can still get
money in the pandemic you could still
build your business in the pandemic you
know and if it's gonna be a pandemic for
the next four months you know i really
suggest everybody figure out what they
gonna do in the next four months it's
always about the long-run game it's
always about the war see sometimes we
have to lose the battle to win the war I
do it all the time and you have no ego
with it you know I'm saying so as long
as you weren't in the war playing
worried about the Bell you know the
battle is just to learn from the war is
what you're trying to win but you got to
really understand what your war is see I
know what my war is my war is I want to
have a television network any battle in
between that I don't care about it
because there's so little in minimal and
and when I went at this television
network game when I win at that game you
know what it looks like the win at
television I'm a visual eyes with it
with it what it looks like to win at
television it's a billy a real one and I
had no partners you know and that was my
dream I might go I want to do this on my
own I don't have no politics I don't
have nobody's mouth I don't want to deal
with nobody friends I just want to do
this on my own
you know I don't want to be about no
ocean you know I mean like again it's
cool to have done cool but to me what
makes you valid what makes you cold
valid is what you're doing currently you
know it's cool to have done flush and
keep doing it you know I mean you know
like if you had a hit record 20 years
ago and that's the same record that you
performing at your show you know it's
time for a new hit at the end of the day
being at the same exact place for 20
years to me as a loss I think you have
to evolve you know every single year
you have to do new things so that's the
reason why I like in real business your
business has to at least you have to
like plan for your business to grow 10%
every year or she don't have a healthy
business you know I mean so in for me
and unless I'm moving forward like I
don't mind everything I did but I got to
lose I just I gotta keep doing lucious I
need new work I gotta have that work and
it gotta be good news like you could you
know like if I was cool 20 years ago and
I didn't know how to be cool now how was
that cool you know that's a fluke that
means it was somebody around me that was
cool that was giving me advice how do I
stay sane during this lockdown I try and
keep myself busy I don't know about you
guys but
when we started getting locked down
about a month and a half ago or actually
two months ago we started to see how
things were going around the world and
how that was going to inform us and as
we as a lockdown became real for us I
thought you know what I'm gonna crush
this I'm gonna give so much done I got
my big whiteboard in my office I wrote
and wrote and wrote like a madman
like a brilliant mind was that it was
that the name of that movie with Russell
Crowe I mean I was that was that and
before you know it you just you wind up
being so damn busy that I'm busier now
than I was you know again yeah babies
and everything else that we're dealing
with the one thing I would make sure to
do who made for us in the in this
situation is every day is you know
really just trying to be as present as
possible with my babies my wife which
was just you know I was busy before so
in a way this is the silver lining that
I was talking about that that I'm able
to recognize is that you know this
everything that we're dealing with and
this is a hard hard thing that we're
dealing with right now the silver lining
is that it's juicing its enable me to
spend more time at home with my babies
and that's really gonna beautiful thing
is but we've been rolling stones for a
very very long time so it's been so good
it's been so good because I've seen
sides of my babies and my children and
my wife that I had not seen before it I
mean that the best way it's just really
so beautiful just from the morning I
wake up into the morning I'd bring my
ass to bed you know it's just me and my
girls I got a house full of estrogen and
I love it don't sell investments follow
the plan so many of you have read
chapter 3 and chapter 7 of my book and
you know that I talked about low cost
long term investing and you know that I
talked about how the market goes up and
down and up and down
but over time it tends to go up and an
average return of approximately seven to
eight percent per year you notice I said
an average some years it could go up 25%
some years it could drop 14% but on
average that is what the historical
return tells us because I've read enough
and because I've been involved in the
personal finance world for a long time
and because I've been through recessions
with smaller amounts of money in my
account to me this was just a small test
to be able to follow my own plan and my
plan says stick with the plan keep
investing as I've always done and in
fact if I have extra money go ahead and
add that to the market now this is
really interesting because as recently
as today I posted someone who wrote me
and I have to have to read you guys what
this person sent me because it's it's
quite the opposite
let me show you here how do I do this
I'm trying to look at my own IG story
right now
well I'm live on Instagram yeah Wow this
is a never attempted this anyway let me
just tell you this person said they were
like we're meet i read your whole book
it was great unfortunately last week i
got scared and i sold all my investments
what should i do i was like i posted it
to i gene that was like what would you
say to this person there's a person who
has the information they know all about
long-term returns etc but it doesn't
matter because emotionally they did not
connect with it they didn't believe it
and so they made a huge tragic money
mistake if you can simply not make a
huge money mistake right now that is a
huge benefit to you over the long term
and if you could keep investing Wow
over the long term you'll probably do
very very well so that's rule number two
keep investing don't sell my investments
if you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there these weird times
that we're living in with the corona
virus and the pandemic